been really fun to be able to like push
myself to kind of a new level with the
stunts and stuff between explosions
multi-level crashes and intricate set
designs spider-man no way home has it
all
we're peeling back the curtain to bring
you the on-set world of your friendly
neighborhood spidey let's jump in
the real magic comes from the electrical
department there's no shortage of cgi in
this scene but we are quite impressed
with the practical effects strange's
witch pot is levitating if you weren't
paying attention with the use of a blue
rig they made easy work of this shot and
did you notice the rotating lights on
the floor surrounding cumberbatch while
he casts the spell there's also one
completely real puddle of water they're
standing in here's hoping their shoes
are waterproof or that would make for a
very uncomfortable day on set it's
really exciting and the film's shaping
up to be something special alfred molina
was tossing those cars like they were
hot wheels this bit where the car
smashes into the wall actually looks so
crazy they built an elevated road just
for this scene
when the car starts falling to its doom
with the mit assistant vice chancellor
inside one gigantic rig was used to tip
the whole thing although we don't
imagine paula newsom was inside at this
point and how about this car that's
literally folding in on itself or the
moment where peter is ripping the door
off the car it's definitely not brute
strength that tears it off more than
likely it's mechanics even behind the
scenes we're wondering how did he do
that safely every stunt that we did in
that film is practical you know there
are there are digital elements to it but
you know we were doing it for real
cinema the one place explosions are
generally a good thing we've never felt
so alive watching a fight take place
before marvel did a truly fantastic job
of keeping this sequence gripping from
the beginning to the end
and one part that was absolutely
terrifying was this explosion all done
by pyrotechnics on their fancy schmancy
road talk about an introduction it gives
you an endless amount of possibilities
what we can create and you know we
really did leave no stone unturned
between a dark och and a hard place up
against a blue screen with no tentacles
to be seen since their cgi and no
spider-man suit in sight due to the fact
it's a nanotech heavy moment this shot
looks less than intimidating hopefully
it only took them one take or they had
spare cement mimicking pillars around i
didn't want to just kind of come back
and replicate what we'd done before it
was important to me to arrive as if this
was the first time one high school
sounds bad enough let alone two while
the interior of the high school is shot
at frederick douglass in atlanta the
exterior is done at franklin k lane
educational campus in brooklyn new york
what's kind of cool is that due to the
pandemic no other movies were allowed to
shoot in these locations spider-man got
special permissions since they'd already
filmed far from home shots there there's
roughly a hundred extras in this scene
but the magic of cinema made the crowd
feel a whole lot larger at its thickest
the crowd only gets like four layers
deep it's been incredibly special they
destroyed the tower bridge last time
only the top part of the skull of the
statue of liberty is real come on did
you really expect them to get the rights
to film on the statue of liberty's head
part of us is relieved to see that
gigantic shield drop as much as we love
captain america it just felt like they
defaced the statue of liberty in the
process besides the shield made for one
of the coolest locations in the movie
but yeah i mean i thought it was the
coolest thing also like i guess you know
visual effects i'm just crashing through
this bit where peter is crashing through
the floors is actually quite impressive
other than a blue screen backdrop and
soft blue matte all of this is actually
happening he actually crashed through
three floors no cgi do you think he fell
through three floors at once or do you
think they filmed this stunt floor by
floor you're gonna have your stun double
be doing that i'm like nope no no no
atlanta wants to be a part of it new
york the sanctorum was rebuilt from
scratch for no way home in atlanta both
its interior and exterior but we'll get
to the interior in just a sec only the
first floor of the sanctorum exterior
set was even built above that it had to
be created with cgi despite it being
filmed in atlanta it still had roots in
new york though the team scrounged for a
lot of their set pieces like the lights
and fire hydrants from a prop shop in
the big apple you won't know that it's
not in new york when you see it it was
pretty typical
a typical process it just was on a much
grander scale does the snowy storm
symbolize the chaos in dr strange's
heart from the frost on the walls to the
shovelable snow being scooped up quite a
few layers of different kinds of fake
snow were needed in this scene and they
also kept out the best part from the
trailer the reason why the snow is even
inside to begin with is it an
unanswerable mystical wizard thing nope
purely a mistake there's been a change
of management at the sanctorum and
director john watts wanted that
reflected through the chaos full credit
to the set designers and all the crew
that just made it look incredible by the
way did steven seem a bit off to you
recklessly endangering the lives of
everyone without taking a moment to
consider maybe talking out any
technicalities or how about how quick he
is to willingly let a bunch of villains
die that doesn't sound like the attitude
of a hero you want to make sure that
the action scenes are driven by
character
number 10.
an ancient basement beneath the vatican
in rome served as the inspiration for
the dungeon in the sanctorum the team
worked for weeks to get the look of the
stone just right the quality of the set
the paintwork the effects just puts you
right back on your game and by the way
the villains were actually trapped
behind plexiglas the magic didn't come
in until later plexiglas would have made
for a much easier escape and while we're
on the topic of the new rooms in the
sanctum sanctorum it's a prime
opportunity to mention the basement
which had some cool little details
carved into the beams did you spot them
there's magic symbols all over them as
well as insignia carved into a floor
paving stone it looks great oh it's
bowing a little bit now
this shot came straight out of a
hallmark christmas movie imagine if it
just snowed in teeny tiny pockets
instead of great big flurries like this
shot from no way home our hearts were
melted by this scene as fast as the fake
snow melted wait that depends if they
used paper or foam
number 12
mj is not a huge fan of the swinging the
real jump between peter and mj was done
from a giant rig off a blue screen
platform always interesting for those
two to land because of their slight
height difference but props to actors
tom holland and zendaya for fighting
back against the stereotype that men
need to be taller than their girlfriends
can we please put mj in heels i then
have to like make myself like be like
which wouldn't naturally be what i do do
you know the secrets of a true leader
specificity is not only what made no way
home great but the preceding mcu
spider-man movies as well
big budget directors don't ignore the
little details they embrace them zendaya
admitted that john watts chose every
single book of mjs intentionally even
the books that are in the background of
shots or in a stack they're all
intentional and very carefully decided
which titles he wanted seen the scale of
what they have is not to be
underestimated
as it turns out the devil is in the
details when it comes to mcu movies and
we don't just mean with the easter eggs
it takes an army of artists and a whole
lot of money to make these sets look
good
what detail in no way home surprised you
the most let us know in the comments and
thanks for watching